[Applause]
and finally new rule when someday soon
an actual brawl breaks out on the floor
of Congress don't say I didn't tell you
it was coming and oh yes it's coming
the kind of thing that we have seen many
times from all over the world
[Applause]
I cannot get enough of that shirt
I
honestly it could be its own show
Parliament fights
[Music]
and uh here's how it starts the reforms
I'm proposing would not apply to those
who are here illegal
and then it becomes a thing
I'm not saying it's a majority
[Applause]
the opioid epidemic give you a copy
you know watching the State of the Union
Address this month it was hard not to
come to the conclusion that the State of
the Union will never just be a monologue
again at least when a Democrat is
president
why is this chick so hyperactive
yeah
she looks like cocaine bear I mean
if she actually were four years old and
I could out this much they'd arrest her
stepfather
honey sit down this is Congress not the
waffle house at three in the morning
it's okay to be crazy just stop being so
needy
and as far as democracy goes this stuff
is the canary in the coal mine do you
really think one day a gun nut like
Lauren bobert isn't going to walk under
the house floor and say I'm here to kick
ass and take names
but since I'm illiterate I'm just going
to be kicking ass
[Applause]
when Americans see bad things happen
overseas we always think well it'll
never happen here we thought that about
terrorism and mask wearing and being one
of those countries where people in
the street
and when we saw a brawling in the very
places where people are supposed to come
together to work out their differences
politely we said
foreigners are funny countries where
democracy is barely a thing and the men
have too much hair on their knuckles
that will never be us
oh it be us
it'd be us real soon a new study
examined 365 incidents of physical
fights and parliaments across the globe
between 1990 and 2018 and discovered the
key to where the fighting takes place
here's who doesn't have Parliament
fights countries with authoritarian
rulers because they just wouldn't allow
it and also because they're too busy
clapping
and the other kind of country that
doesn't throw punches real democracies
like we used to be
the places where fights break out are
the countries that aren't sure which one
they are and that's where we're heading
now maybe in the past I would have said
we need to find a way to love and
respect each other again
but honestly I think that bus has sailed
which is why tonight I'd like to suggest
that our political leaders learn a
lesson from the people who work in one
of America's most successful Industries
this one
Show Business and understand something
very fundamental you can get great
things done and still hate each other's
guts
thank you
it would be easier to name great movies
where the principles didn't hate each
other the editor of Mad Max Fury Road
said Charlize Theron and Tom Harney
didn't want to touch each other they
didn't want to look at each other they
wouldn't face each other if the camera
wasn't actively rolling but the movie
works
director Roman Polanski hated his
Leading Lady Faye Dunaway so much he
refused to give her a bathroom break so
she pissed in a cup and threw it in his
face
the movie they made together Chinatown
which ironically is about hoarding water
at the end of An Officer and a Gentleman
Richard Gere whisks Deborah Winger away
but when the camera stopped he couldn't
wait to drop her
and on Terms of Endearment Winger hated
Shirley McLean someone she farted in her
face
but the movie didn't stink
[Laughter]
Eddie Murphy and John Landis stuck it
out on coming to America but when it was
over and he said that Vic Morrow who had
been decapitated in a stunt gone wrong
on a previous Landis movie had a better
chance of working with Landis again than
I do
ctors have many times hated each other
so much they refused to be on the set
together at the same time even in a
scene they were both in
America loves Bill Murray but you know
who doesn't everyone who's ever worked
with them
well everyone who's ever worked with Ted
Cruz hates him
why can't it work in governments
because I am telling you the list of
people who sucked it up and said I know
we hate each other but we've got a movie
to make is long and impressive
[Music]
thank you
oh and it's not just movies your
favorite TV stars they hate each other
too
these two did
and so did these two on Star Trek
Captain Kirk feuded constantly with Mr
Spock and he's still feuding with Mr
Sulu
and it's no secret there was no love
lost between these two ladies and yet
they found a way to work together on a
show about how men are always the
problem
governments government learn needs to
learn to do the same thing yes here in
terrible horrible immoral show business
we hate each other and yet we still do
our jobs turning your children communist
and gay